we're only two months into the year but
January 2016 saw some big releases like
the witness and Mario and Luigi paper
jam but what were the best-selling games
for last month the NPD group has
revealed the top ten physical games sold
in the u.s. counting down from 10 to 1
the top games are fifa 16 Lego Marvel
Avengers madden NFL 16 Rainbow six siege
minecraft fallout 4 star wars
battlefront NBA 2k16 grand theft auto 5
and call of duty black ops 3 black ops
also topped the list for last November
and December and the entirety of 2015
props to Trey arctor still going strong
the previously mentioned Mario and Luigi
paper jam barely missed the list since
NPD combines numbers across all
platforms the group also noted strong
sales for Nintendo's amoeba figures and
super smash brothers there was no
shortage of games to play this January
but if this top 10 is any indication
most of us have a lot of catching up to
do anyway to stay up to date with all
the gaming news keep it locked to
gamespot
you